4e à
ils sont peintres et jouent en réseau
sur leur ordinateur
et comme tu sais fous d'informatique ne
va pas déconnecté à l'elysée ils
partagent tous ou même connexion sens
fier
en général on avait l'habitude de le
faire en liaison directe c'est-à-dire
par câble mais effectivement c'est une
première pour nous tous autant de
participants de participants que nous
sommes de faire en sorte il est le
secret de cette première c'est la prison
pour cette démonstration les rois de
cette bidouille ont connecté un seul de
leur ordinateur à internet grâce à une
simple prise téléphone et à partir de là
leur ordinateur et c'est ça la prouesse
technique
il leur lit à une antenne ensuite
exactement comme pour la radio l'antenne
distribue aucun aide par guardien la
toux ceux qui sont à proximité de
l'antenne peuvent recevoir l'internet
sans fil et gratuitement aux nouveaux de
les moyens d'accès internet et des
moyens de partage d'informations dans un
budget cette fois ci un peu plus
français c'est à dire on s'arrange
s'arrange on va partager le boîtier
inséré dans n'importe quel ordinateur
suffit pour capter l'internet sans fil
un ordinateur portable pékin si lui
aussi recevoir n'importe où cet internet
sans fil on est alors à mille lieues des
prévisions des grands opérateurs pour
l'internet mobile
ils ont tous misé sur le mps et le
téléphone
portable avec abonnement payant
individuel ici rien de tel alors chez
france télécom on chuchote t on veut
récupérer sa pub était non seulement on
y croit on y croit fortement
on imagine éventuellement de l'opérer
l'aveu d'une technologique vous vous
rendrez 7 on y regarde aujourd'hui le
wheel qui divise des fréquences radio
réservé aux militaires un cabinet de
l'utiliser dans le domaine public
les ça ne devrait pas durer on attend
d'ailleurs mon autorisation
on veut tout l'été des faits de comme
langue des signes